Pray with me and for me really quick
before I share my testimony.
Heavenly Father, we, I'm so humbled
to have the opportunity to share
even just a part of my story.
And I'm reminded that I am not really sharing my story
but I'm sharing your story through me.
The Lord let that be the story that is made known today.
Jesus' name, amen.
Last night, I was having a good conversation
and was reminded that we are a story telling people.
We enjoy telling stories, we enjoy listening to stories
and most everything that you can think of
is part of a story, whether that is your favorite
movie series or your favorite TV show,
sports that you like to watch or anything,
it's all a narrative.
And I think that's what makes it so compelling
and so enjoyable is because it is a narrative.
We were created to love and speak through narrative.
I think that's the power of telling stories.
And what's interesting is that the Bible
is not merely a list of rules or facts or things to do
but it is written as a narrative.
We love stories and we find our significance in stories.
A quote that I really love, at the time I heard it,
it was attributed to Wendell Berry.
I was not able to find it so I can't quote it
exactly for you but I will try and recall it
to the best of my ability because it's stuck
with me since then and it's that people find
their significance from the biggest story
in which they see themselves as playing a role.
And so for me, as I recount God's story through me,
I think the main point that I wanna communicate
is that at different points in my life,
I have believed that the biggest story I was a part of
was not the one that really is the biggest story
which is God's story.
And that lie of believing these other stories
is ultimately what I needed to be saved from
that my sin ultimately flowed out of me believing
that these other stories were more important than God himself.
So the question I have asked or asked myself
and the question I'll ask for you today
as I tell my story is what is the story
that you are believing is the biggest right now
in your life and where do you see yourself playing a role?
In my story, I'm blessed to say that I've never known a time
where I didn't know who God was.
I was raised in a Christian family,
parents who loved the Lord.
We were involved in church very regularly
but there are several stories I find myself
frequently chasing after.
The first one is one that says basically,
I am trying to maximize my own pleasure
and minimize the pain that I get.
And that's somehow the story or the game that I am playing,
the thing that I want to do the most.
And so what does that look like?
Well, in practice, for me, as I was growing up,
I would think outwardly as a people pleaser
in the Bible belt, I'm gonna make sure
that my life looks like it is good,
that I'm going to follow the rules,
I'm not going to stand out too much,
I don't wanna be noticed and I don't wanna be really known.
And so growing up, that's how I lived is in high school,
I really didn't want to be the one that was standing
in front of a group of people sharing anything.
So even standing up here is kind of out of my comfort zone.
That kind of lie that my story is just this side thing
that doesn't really matter.
It's not really a part of anything else.
That lie led to a lot of depression, anxiety.
In fact, in high school, I actually dropped out
of high school, I never graduated.
The depression of just not really finding
my significance anywhere led to why does this even matter?
Lots of questions of self-worth of anxiety
and it led to a lot of hiding whatever pain I had,
just trying to hide it away,
not letting it be known because at the end of the day,
I wanted other people to think that I had it all together
because that was the story where I found my significance.
I believed that I was the main character of my story,
that somehow I could do XYZ to earn other people's approval
and that doing that would ultimately bring joy
and yet it did not.
The end result of chasing that pleasure in secret
while projecting to other stability
was at the end of the day, depression and falling apart.
But no one else would know that.
I kept it hidden pretty well.
My sister might beg to differ.
She might have noticed it more than others
but at the end of the day, that's kind of who I was.
Dropped out of high school, I got my GED,
started working immediately and thought then that,
oh, well this extra income can then provide extra pleasures.
So why don't I chase after those?
Because maybe the problem is that I'm not
finding enough pleasure or the right pleasures.
So I started trying to go down every avenue
you could possibly think of chasing what that looked like.
At one point, I point back to this time because
there was a time where I was in a car with a friend
and we were going off to do something I can't remember.
We lived together at the time
and I remember turning to him and thinking like
something in my mind just changed
and I can't put an explanation on this
other than to say that God at some point just said,
you are mine, I have chosen you for a bigger story
than this one.
I turned to him and said,
I can't continue whatever it is we're doing.
And it really confused him at the time
because I don't know that either of us
had really consciously decided to go off
on this side tangent of living our own stories.
But at that point, at that moment,
I can say honestly that that was the turning point
in my life where God himself reached into my life
and told me I have called you
to something greater than this.
But contrary to what you might think
when you see stories in various movies
where the turning point all of a sudden turns
into this glorious return,
that's not exactly how my story went
because it took a while.
You see the path to following Christ
didn't immediately unfold before me.
I still was drawn to this story
and still believed in my heart
that at the end of the day,
I'm kind of this side character,
this person over here,
God's story and who Jesus was
is not a part of my story.
Like those are different things that disconnected.
And because I believed that,
I would follow Christ and try to go
and learn, read the Bible,
and then continue to try and do my side project
of well maybe I can try and maximize pleasure
and minimize pain in other ways.
Specifically on the minimizing pain front
that became like my main goal
is this side project of I'm going to
lose myself in video games
or I am going to lose myself
in binge watching TV
rather than focusing on the goal
that God has set before me
which was taking up my cross and following Jesus.
At the end of the day, return was not easy
because I was still trying to do it by myself.
In spoil alert, you cannot do it on your own.
Beyond the obvious that Jesus is the one
that paid the price for us and you need him,
you also need each other.
And I needed someone else
or other people to talk to
about the things that I was trying to hide for so long.
Around my junior year of, I guess senior year,
going into senior year of college,
I had a broken engagement
where I feel like I fell finally to rock bottom.
This was after the turning point in my life.
I remember the conversation that happened before.
Like I feel like rock bottom happened after that
which is interesting.
I don't know necessarily what to do that still
with this story and my story is still being written.
And yet at that point, I remember distinctly opening up
and talking to other people about what was going on
in my heart and not just what I wanted them to see.
And that confession of what was really happening
in my life started to change my heart.
It was a slow healing process after that.
I remember I spent about a year of just walking around
Samford University's campus probably every night.
It's really calm.
It's a great place to walk if you ever want to.
But that's what I did as I walked around their campus
probably every night for about a year.
I remember even the song we sang this morning,
I stand amazed.
I would sing songs in my head as I was walking
and I remember God just continually telling me
and comforting me that like,
he was telling me that you are a part of my story.
You play a significant role in my story.
You are not a side character that does not have any purpose.
I have called you for something greater
and I want you to follow me.
Slowly over time after that,
and for the past six or seven years,
that has become more and more meaningful to me.
I guess in closing with my story,
I really just want to recount to you what God's story is
rather than focus on how God has done anything through me.
And I was reminded of that as we sang
before the throne as well.
I'm just gonna read these words back
because I think it's worth just pausing and meditating
on what this actually means.
It says, because the sinless Savior died,
my sinful soul is counted free.
For God the just is satisfied to look on him
and pardon me.
And at the end of the day, I didn't do anything
to earn that pardon.
And yet God has looked on me.
It's hard to imagine because I really didn't deserve
any of this.
I know many of us in the room probably feel the same way.
I would just leave us with a couple of things.
One is I continue to sit with the question
of what is the story that I'm believing day in and day out?
It's one of the questions I ask myself every day
because I find myself consistently falling
into the old patterns of my life.
But also knowing that at the end of the day
it's God's story that I am a part of.
And my part matters.
And your part matters.
He knows you specifically.
He's called you specifically.
So for me the call was to come out of hiding
whatever it is I was trying to hide
and to be an authentic person.
To live in following who Jesus is.
So each and every day that's the goal.
Obviously I fall far short of that every day.
But I'm always reminded that it's God's grace in my life.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you so much for sharing that.
We really appreciate your openness and what you shared.
So grateful that the Lord in this story
has brought you and Mary into the life of this church
as well as the kids too.
Let's turn together to Psalm 6.
Psalm 6.
Much of what we were just hearing,
we hear in David's own story,
the author of this Psalm.
This points us to the Lord's story.
So I'll read Psalm 6.
And we'll pray and walk through this together.
Oh Lord, rebuke me not in your anger,
nor discipline me in your wrath.
Be gracious to me, oh Lord, for I am languishing.
Heal me, oh Lord, for my bones are troubled.
My soul is also greatly troubled.
But you, oh Lord, how long?
Turn, oh Lord, deliver my life.
Save me for the sake of your steadfast love,
for in death there is no remembrance of you.
And, Shale, who will give you praise?
I am weary with my moaning every night I flood my bed with tears.
I drench my couch with weeping.
My eye wastes away because of grief.
It grows weak because of all my foes.
Depart from me all you workers of evil,
for the Lord has heard the sound of my weeping.
The Lord has heard my plea.
The Lord accepts my prayer.
All my enemies shall be ashamed and greatly troubled.
They shall turn back and be put to shame in a moment.
This is the word of the Lord.
So Lord, I pray that you would speak to us now
for your servants are listening.
Amen.
If you've never come across
the Japanese-American artist Makoto Fujimura,
I would very much encourage you to look at some of his artwork.
I'm sure I pronounced his name wrong,
just in case you're wondering that too.
But he's a painter based in New York City,
but he's also written a number of helpful things
on the connection between art and faith.
And one thing that he's written about
is this Japanese art form called kinsugi.
Now kinsugi is basically the art of repairing broken pottery.
And actually the word is a combination of two words.
And one of the words is mending
and the other word is gold.
So basically like when a ceramic bowl is broken,
instead of throwing it away,
you would save that bowl because one day
you'll then either bring that to an artist
or you're the artist and you'll then take that
and you will mend it.
And instead of mending it in such a way,
like you would say like super glue
where you don't wanna see the cracks anymore
towards trying to get it back to that perfect condition,
what's done instead is they produce a lacquer
which is mixed with gold and they do it in such a way
that you can still see exactly where the cracks were,
but now it's joined together by this lacquer and this gold.
And so that is now even more valuable
than it was before it was broken.
And it's there not to be discarded,
but to be passed on to future generations.
So through the brokenness comes beauty.
And this is what we see in Psalm six.
David is before us as a man who is utterly broken,
but his story isn't over
because God takes the broken pieces of his life
and he creates something beautiful
that will bless generations to come,
including us sitting here this morning.
So it's on display here for us in Psalm six.
And as we look at this together,
we see the God who did this in David's life
and we can know that he can do the same thing
in ours as well.
He can take our brokenness
and create something beautiful.
So with that in view,
we're gonna learn about David's distress,
what he was going through,
but we're also gonna see what he does with his distress
as he brings this before the Lord.
And then finally we'll see what the Lord then does
with the broken pieces of his life, so to speak.
So what kind of distress is David experiencing?
All right, so a couple of weeks ago,
we saw in Psalm four that there is joy to be had
and David knew what it was like to rejoice in the Lord
and the joy that he knew was greater
than the other people he recognized around him.
So there's a deep joy for us to know as followers of Christ,
but that does not mean that the Christian life is
all smiles all the time.
And to pretend that it is would only breed hypocrisy.
The fact is is that this side of eternity,
we live in a broken world.
And so we will experience the pain and the sorrow
that comes with that brokenness.
I love what Zach S. Wein said.
He said, in this fallen world, sadness is an act of sanity.
Our tears, the testimony of the sane.
In other words, it's a reflection of the broken reality
of the world in which we lived or we live in.
So in David's testimony here, he's allowing this brokenness
to be highlighted rather than hidden away.
And so we're gonna see it and we're gonna see a couple
of things as we look at his distress.
We're gonna see the nature of his distress
and then kind of like where it's coming from.
All right, so what does he tell us about his distress here?
Well, he describes it as, you might say intense.
So you look in, at the end of verse two,
he talks about being troubled, but then he gets
to verse three and he says, my soul also is
greatly troubled, but you, oh Lord, how long?
So he's moved from troubled to actually know,
let's intensify this, I'm greatly troubled.
There's a growing intensity. His troubles are severe.
He also tells us that his troubles are relentless.
So he cries out, oh Lord, how long?
So this isn't something that you cry out
just in a moment of difficulty.
This is something you cry out when day after day
or night after night, you're in this distressing situation.
So you're crying out, oh Lord, how long?
This is what David's going through.
He talks about this being night after night in verse six.
He talks about how he's experiencing this
on lots of different fronts.
It's almost like a man drowning and when he comes up
for air then the next wave hits
and then the next wave hits.
This is the relentless situation he's in.
He also talks about the extensiveness of his trouble.
John Calvin, the reformer, once described the book of Psalms
as an anatomy of all parts of the soul.
This is kind of what we see here.
We see trouble hitting David on lots of different fronts.
It's all packed into this one Psalm.
So when he says in verse three, my soul is greatly troubled.
Don't think about that as like differentiating
between like body and spirit.
So what he's saying there, when he's saying my soul
is troubled, he's talking about his whole being.
That's why it's being conveyed by that word.
So all parts of me are experiencing this great distress.
He talks about the physical side of it.
It's debated but he could be suffering from physical illness
as he's writing this Psalm.
So he talks about languishing.
Literally that means he's weak.
He's experiencing weakness.
He prays for healing because of his bones being troubled.
So it could be metaphorically but it could be
he's actually experiencing pain continually in his bones.
He definitely talks about facing death in verse five.
Interesting.
What he says about death, you may have noticed that
and thought, what do we think about that?
For in death there's no remembrance of you.
In shale, who will give you praise?
Let me just say kind of as a sidebar here,
what he's saying here isn't a denial
about what the rest of Scripture teaches
about our existence after death,
about life beyond the grave.
But remember what we're talking about,
our soul, our whole being.
So what does God desire?
God desires that his people praise him
with their whole selves.
And so he's saying, if I die,
if my body goes to the grave,
I won't be able to do that.
So God wants us to praise him with our whole selves
in his creation.
He's saying, Lord, death is going to bring an end to that.
But he also talks about his emotional pain.
He's suffering intense emotional distress.
And actually there's more attention
given to this part of his distress
than anything else within the Psalm.
There's a real emphasis here.
So let's see what he says in verse six again.
He says, I am weary with my moaning.
Every night I flood my bed with tears.
So it's this kind of storm language going on.
I'm flooding my bed with tears.
I drench my couch with weeping.
All right, so David isn't just a little tearful here.
So instead of sleeping, like night after night,
he is weeping.
And his bed is now drenched with tears.
He says, my eye wastes away because of grief.
It grows weak because of all my foes.
So he's got that kind of thousand-yard stare
of a man who has experienced depths of sorrow.
So I love the book of Psalms for many reasons,
but this is one of them because it describes
not just the kind of external troubles we face in life,
but what it feels like to experience those troubles.
And that is just as real and painful
as the physical aspects as well.
And they can be experienced by godly people.
So David is a man after God's own heart,
and yet he experiences these depths of sorrow.
And you can read about this throughout Christian history as well.
I mean, one of my kind of heroes is Charles Spurgeon,
this pastor in the 19th century in London.
And the Lord used him greatly in so many ways.
And he struggled with intense physical pain,
but also severe depression for a lot of his ministry.
But here's what he said,
which ties into what we're looking at here.
The mind can descend far lower than the body,
for in it there are bottomless pits.
The flesh can bear only a certain number of wounds
and no more, but the soul can bleed in ten thousand ways
and die over and over again each hour.
Maybe you know something of that kind of pain,
the tears, the emotional distress that David is describing.
I know I identify with what is being said here.
But there's also a spiritual component.
There's physical distress, emotional distress,
but right out of the gate in the psalm,
he is wrestling with the Lord.
Verse one, he soon cries out,
but you, oh Lord, how long?
Instead of experiencing God's deliverance,
he's experiencing what feels like God's absence
in the midst of these deep sorrows.
So David doesn't just describe his troubles,
he also gives us some clues as to what the source of his trouble might be.
And before we look at those kind of clues
about the source of the trouble,
I just want to acknowledge that
that is a really difficult subject to even bring up.
Like if you've got a sprained ankle,
it's easy to identify, oh, you're experiencing pain in your ankle?
Well, it's sprained.
Let's raise that up and let it rest
and so you can identify the source of the pain and deal with it.
But it's not always that straightforward
when it comes to emotional distress.
And sometimes it can be a reaction to a specific loss,
but I know I've been through seasons
where I could not tell you for the life of me
why I feel so low.
You can't point to the source of that.
And it can be even harder to work through thinking through that
when you're in the disorienting fog of this kind of distress
being described here in the Psalm.
And by the way, that's one of the many reasons
why we shouldn't suffer in silence.
Why it's important to, you know, as Caleb just shared,
just being open and vulnerable with one another
because we need one another in this.
And this Psalm, like the other Psalms,
this is corporate worship here.
We're praying this together. We're lamenting together.
So there's a togetherness when it comes to our grief that we need.
So open up and let's weep together
and see what we can do to come alongside one another.
That being said, all that being said, that kind of caveat there,
David wrestles with the source of his problem.
He talks about his enemies in verses 7 to 10.
We see that he's surrounded by enemies.
They certainly factor into the trouble that he is experiencing.
They are on the attack.
It seems like they're even gloating over what David is experiencing.
And like David's enemies, sometimes there are external factors
beyond our control that kind of pull the rug out from underneath us.
And we didn't see it coming, but there it is.
You know, like at the Barrens game the other night,
I was scared to death of a foul ball kind of coming up and hitting you.
Life can be that way. You can just get clobbered with something
you didn't see coming and you just then experience the distress that comes with that.
You know, it could be circumstances like loss and then the grief that follows.
It could be other medical issues happening where there's like a physiological component
or a psychological component where there's a real medical thing happening there.
And experiencing those things doesn't necessarily mean that we've done something wrong
or that we're being punished for a particular sin.
I mean, read the book of Job.
Job was a righteous man and he suffered horrendously.
And the Lord rebukes his friends when they try to diagnose and say,
well, let me tell you what the source of your problem is.
It is your sin.
They're rebuked by the Lord.
However, in this instance, David doesn't just speak about those external factors.
He wrestles with his own sinfulness.
He wrestles with the discipline of the Lord.
He says, verse one, oh Lord, rebuke me not in your anger,
nor discipline me in your wrath.
So this Psalm is not just a Psalm of lament.
By the way, this is the first of seven penitential Psalms where it's like giving words to our repentance
as we're repenting before the Lord in prayer, coming to him in that way.
So David doesn't mention though a specific sin here.
Nevertheless, he's beginning his prayer by asking God for mercy.
So he knows that God is sovereign over everything and he's wrestling with the question
of whether or not he is experiencing this as punishment from God.
So what do we do with that?
I mean, we can see the situation with Job's.
We won't go back there, but what do we do with David wrestling with this, saying,
Lord, is this punishment here?
Well, in a general way, the brokenness of this world and our own brokenness is part of God's judgment upon sin in a general way.
Right? So sin is entered in the world and God's judgment has come because of sin.
Our brokenness is the result.
So yes, that is what we are experiencing when we are feeling our brokenness.
So in that general sense, it is an experience of that judgment.
But last week, we saw that when we come to God, we should approach him with humility and dependent upon his mercy.
And we never get beyond that.
Now, as his children, we should not live in constant fear of his wrath.
Remember Romans 8 1, we, we, we, that last week there is now therefore no condemnation to those who are in Christ Jesus.
So if you're in him, you are not condemned.
So we shouldn't live in constant fear of his wrath.
And yet, every time we come to the Lord, we are utterly dependent upon his mercy.
But there's no other way to come to God apart from dependent on who he is and how merciful he is.
Right? So we come to him with humility.
So although we're not condemned, we can, as his children, experience the Lord's discipline.
But even then, he is carrying this out in love for our good.
The scripture speaks about times when we can sin against God and how it can be good to experience grief over sin
because it drives us to repentance and change.
It drives us back to the Lord.
So 2 Corinthians chapter 7, verses 9 and 10.
Let me just read those verses.
Paul writes and says, as it is, I rejoice not because you were grieved.
He's not rejoicing over the grief itself, but because you were grieved into repenting.
For you felt a godly grief so that you suffered no loss through us.
For godly grief produces a repentance that leads to salvation without regrets,
whereas worldly grief produces death.
So Paul says, I'm not rejoicing in this grief that you were experiencing,
but if it leads you to repentance and coming to the Lord, then I'm rejoicing in that.
Know that the Lord can use it in that way.
But we should also be aware of what author Mark Manel refers to as phantom guilt.
I don't know if you know what phantom pain is.
I'm not a doctor, but I'm told that people who have amputated limbs can experience phantom pains.
In other words, they experience a pain that's associated with that part of the body
although that part of the body were still there.
It's a very real, visceral pain.
So in the same way, when we're going through some of these deep valleys
and we're dependent on the Lord's mercy, we're coming to Him.
We've been forgiven. We've confessed our sin.
When we're in that place of deep sorrow, something of like a phantom guilt can remain.
We can know that we're forgiven.
We can believe that.
Confess our sin and say, He is faithful and just to forgive us for our sins
and cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
And yet, in that time of emotional distress, we can feel a sense of guilt and shame more acutely
even though all that's been dealt with at the cross in Christ.
Well, it's hard to tell how David got here,
whether it's a specific sin or just a general sense of his sinfulness
that he's feeling a need for God's mercy.
Nevertheless, he is broken.
And in that, as I said earlier, disorienting fog of despair, it can be hard to find your way.
That's so wonderful we have this Psalm here because David kind of shows us the way.
He shows us what it's like to walk by faith even in the midst of that kind of despair.
So let's see what David does with his distress.
He brings his brokenness to the Lord.
Five times here. He says, Oh Lord, oh Lord, oh Lord, five times.
And as he does so, we see three things that we can do with our distress,
that we can do in the midst of our despair.
So first of those things is this, pour out your tears to the Lord.
Pour out your tears to God.
So David cries and expresses his pain to the Lord.
In the book of Psalms, there's lots of different kinds of Psalms,
but the most common are Psalms of lament.
This is one of those Psalms of lament, about a third of the Psalms are Psalms of lament
or contained lament.
So we clearly need to learn to lament.
So what is that? What does it mean to lament?
Well, it's not just venting negative emotions.
It's bringing our pain to God in prayer.
It's laying our distress before the Lord right where we are
and wrestling with him and then setting our hopes in him.
This is what this kind of song of sorrow is inviting us to do,
to express these feelings to the Lord in prayer.
So pouring out your tears before the Lord is an act of faith.
So we're not just weeping. We're not just saying, oh, we're saying, oh Lord.
And God invites us here in the Psalms and elsewhere to come to him,
not just when everything is resolved and we understand why everything happened that happens.
But right in the middle of our distress, we come to him then.
That's what he's calling us to as our loving, heavenly Father.
He wants us to pour our hearts out to him right where we are.
Pouring out your tears to him is a form of prayer.
David says this amazing thing in verse 8.
This is probably the first thing that stood out to me as I read this psalm this past week.
He says, the Lord has heard the sound of my weeping.
So he's describing his weeping as a form of prayer.
He's not saying the Lord has heard my articulation of good theology.
The Lord hasn't heard my eloquence.
He's saying the Lord has heard the sound of my weeping.
Like a parent running to a weeping child and receiving them.
He's receiving our tears as prayer.
You know, in Romans 8 talks about us groaning before the Lord and how the spirit of God helps us in our groaning to pray.
You may feel utterly heartbroken and it may feel a sense of God's absence.
Nevertheless, the Lord is near.
He hears your weeping.
Psalm 34 in verse 18 says, the Lord draws near to the brokenhearted
and saves those who are crushed in spirit.
He runs to the cry of his children and not one tear, not one tear is wasted.
Psalm 56 in verse 8 says that he keeps our tears in a bottle.
I love that image.
He doesn't waste any of it.
So pour out your tears to the Lord, but then also pray for the turning of God.
That might sound unusual.
That's what it says.
Psalm 54, David prays, turn, oh Lord, deliver my life, save me for the sake of your steadfast love.
So what does it mean to pray for God's turning?
We've seen David turning to the Lord in an attitude of humble repentance.
Now he's boldly asking for the Lord to turn to him.
So what David is saying here is praying that the Lord would turn.
He's praying that God would make his steadfast love known to him again by saving him from this distress that he is in.
He doesn't know how long this is going to continue, but he knows the character of the God he's praying to.
And he's saying, Lord, make yourself known again and make yourself known in saving me.
It's like Corey Ten Boom said.
She said, never be afraid to trust an unknown future to a known God.
He said, God, I know that you are a God who is gracious and merciful, slow to anger and abounding in steadfast love.
Lord, make that known.
So when we pray that God would turn, what we're praying is this.
We're praying that God would make the beauty of his love known by mending our brokenness.
It's like, Lord, make the beauty of your love known by mending my brokenness.
So where can we look to see that God loves us in this way?
David has this confidence in the Lord. Where do we see the character of God revealed?
This confidence that is revealed perfectly in Jesus.
It is in Jesus that we see that God loves broken people just like us so much that he was willing to step right into our brokenness.
To take on flesh, step into our humanity.
And when we look to Jesus, we see that Jesus experienced our sorrows.
He's described as a man of sorrows and acquainted with grief.
You know, Easter time we saw him weeping at the grave of a friend.
John chapter 12 and verse 27, he may be echoing what we're reading in Psalm 6 here.
He uses very similar words to Psalm 6-3. Jesus says, now my soul is troubled.
David says, my soul is troubled. And Jesus says, now my soul is troubled.
Well, where's he heading? He's heading to the cross.
And he goes to the Garden of Gethsemane. And there we see him weeping before the Lord.
Experiencing depths of sorrow beyond imagining.
In Hebrews chapter 5 and verse 7, it says that he prayed with tears and with loud cries.
And then when he goes to the cross, there his body is broken.
He suffers there for our sin.
So David fears the Lord's wrath.
He's mindful of it there in verse 1. He's praying that the Lord would be merciful to him.
Well, we can pray that looking to the cross, knowing that the judgment that we deserve was born by him there.
However I'm feeling, I can confidently cast myself upon the mercy of God because Jesus died in my place.
So I can pray knowing that Jesus sympathizes with my weakness.
But also that he's able to save because of what he's accomplished for us in his death and in his resurrection.
And we can lament in hope.
So whatever we face, we can lay hold of the hope that we will dwell with him forever in a new creation.
So scripture in Revelation 21 and verse 4 says this is what we have to look forward to as we pray and we grieve in hope.
It says, the new creation is coming where he will wipe away every tear from our eyes and death shall be no more.
Neither shall there be mourning nor crying nor pain anymore for the former things have passed away.
So when we pray, turn, oh Lord, we're saying make yourself known to us in Jesus, the Jesus who will one day wipe away our tears.
And also, as he pours out his tears before the Lord, he says, Lord, turn, make yourself known to me.
And then he proclaims the truth of God.
He says, verse 8, depart from me all you workers of evil.
So David's accusers are sure of his demise but David doesn't concede.
So he defiantly says, depart from me.
David's words here, by the way, foreshadow the words of Jesus.
Matthew 723, he says there's also coming a day when he will then say to some, depart from me.
I never knew you.
Depart from me, you workers of lawlessness.
So you're either among those who have put their trust in Christ.
And we'll know the comfort of being with him forever, where you're among those who he says, depart from me, I never knew you.
But David's words here are expressing a defiant faith.
It's interesting that the Psalms worded even that last section in a way that is expressing confidence.
And yet, it's still in the midst of what he's feeling.
So there's no indication that the sorrow has gone away.
Nevertheless, he's speaking confidently.
The Lord has heard me.
The Lord has answered my plea, departs.
So you can imagine the tears in his eyes and the quiver in his voice as he's saying this.
He's confident the Lord will deliver me.
So confidence in Jesus doesn't always look like the absence of sorrow.
That is coming, but we may have to wait.
We may have to defiantly speak the truth of the Lord in the midst of our sorrows as well.
Zach, S. Y. N. again said conversion to Jesus isn't heaven, but it's foretaste.
This side of heaven grace secures, but it doesn't cure us.
So faith sometimes looks like a defiant trust right in the middle of our sorrows.
And our confidence must be in Christ, in Christ alone, and not in our feelings, even our feelings about him.
We walk by faith and not by sight.
And sometimes the sight that we're not walking by is our kind of sensory perception of how things are going.
I'm saying, Lord, I trust you not how I'm feeling about this or what my circumstances are telling me.
So whatever you're facing, however you're feeling, through faith, through faith rather, look to Christ.
And in him you can declare that you are accepted in the beloved, that your God abounds instead fast love.
And in Jesus' name, he has heard your prayer.
He will bring beauty from the brokenness.
So what happens when we bring our broken lives to the Lord and place them in his hands?
He takes the broken pieces and he creates something that is beautiful,
something that is even better than it would have been had it never been broken in the first place.
So what is the gold that shines in the broken places?
What's the grace, mercy, love of the Lord?
It's the glory of the gospel shining through broken vessels.
It's the beauty of Christ.
Let's pray.
Lord, we thank you so much that you are God of mercy and steadfast love.
Lord, we thank you that you are God who receives us in our brokenness, makes us new.
We thank you that you invite us to weep before you, that you hear the sound of our weeping.
So Lord, I pray that you would help us to bring our tears to you but also to place our trust in you.
And as we do so, Lord, we pray that your beauty would be displayed even through our brokenness.
In Jesus' name, amen.